mais aujourd'hui l'essentiel de ce qui
arrive dans nos assiettes revient
d'animaux qui ont été nourries à
domicile et ceux là sont tout à fait à
la merci du savant qui peut à tout
moment décider du menu et en contrôler
l'efficacité dans les laboratoires de
l'inra l'institut national de la
recherche agronomique
on s'est donc attaché à rendre le plus
efficace possible
le pionner du bovin cet animal pourtant
bien vivant n'est en fait qu'un appareil
de mesure une chaîne de fabrication à
l'entrée en pèse la nourriture ingérée
une nourriture étudiez bien sûr et à
l'autre extrémité de la chaîne on pèsera
aussi les sorties
pour juger de ce qui s'est passé entre
les deux à l'intérieur de l'usiné
vivantes ont fait des prélèvements à
tous les stades de fabrication grâce à
des fistules ainsi pourra-t-on forcé et
même accélérer la capacité des bleus à
produire de la viande les fistules sont
ainsi un livre ouvert sur le mystère de
la genèse nos plats favoris
pour ce technicien la panse d'un boeuf
est une source de savoir dans laquelle
il puise abondamment dans cette es qu
elle il y à déjà la promesse des
biftecks de demain
[Applaudissements]
si ce moment c'est la clinique
vous arrêtez ça c'est démonter avant si
la fistule est un livre de leçon de
choses
eh bien disons qu'ils s'ouvrent
facilement et qu'il est quelquefois plus
difficile de le refermer encore quelques
efforts et même quelques coups de pompe
à vélo et le hublot sur la vie sera à
nouveau fermée plus étanche que jamais
grâce à ces incursions dans les
entrailles de la bête
on sait maintenant que pour améliorer le
rendement des bovins il faut abandonner
les fourrages d'antan ce qu'il faut
maintenant c'est une nourriture
particulier fait de maïs traitées ou
même le plus souvent de granulés de
luzerne ainsi l'animal mange plus dans
le même temps et cette nourriture ont
filé traverse plus vite et plus
efficacement son organisme producteurs
[Musique]